the farms freaky secret was finally
uncovered and we need to talk it out
together on Sweetwater secrets
[Music]
hello Ripper babes
I'm your host Liana Galera and this is
your Sweetwater Secrets after-show for
episode 317 chapter 52 the raid
now today I'll be shouting out my
unfiltered hisses and kisses showing you
a new interview with Cole Sprouse and
for wreaking out about a certain bug
head zine start from the beginning
but first let's do a quick pass at all
the plot points you need to know in the
blue and gold breakdown still set on
discovering the farms freaky secrets
Betty tugged on Cheryl's Jason loving
heartstrings and convinced our lady in
red to go undercover as a potential new
recruit at the open house I'm in cousin
Betty used her mom's old recording
equipment and sent her spider off to
weave a web of lies for Edgar ever never
but thanks to Edie's great listening
skills and ridiculously attractive face
Cheryl was soon under the leaders spell
she's also a great listener but just why
did our fearless HBIC suddenly want to
be a farming because mr. ever never is a
yummy stack well the shocking revelation
of the week is that apparently the farm
has the ability to resurrect people
because Cheryl said she's having full-on
conversations with her dead twin brother
barb gave me back my brother oh and
Alice Cooper is also in contact with her
deceased son Charles he's the most
beautiful boy I have ever seen yeah now
Betty finally got her chance to sit down
with Edgar and ask all her most burning
questions but it seems like we'll have
to wait until the next episode for those
answers meanwhile over at the Jones
family in the Cooper house long story
short but Jughead was determined to keep
taking the law into his own hands
despite the fact that his father is the
sheriff and his mother as the reigning
drug queen of Riverdale mm-hmm
we discovered that the gargoyles moved
their candy drug lab into a seedy
apartment building but the only reason
we found that out is from Mad Dog when
he went to go visit his grandma and
taken over by drug dealers and weird
masks and that only happened because
Archie and Veronica blackmailed the
governor into
hardening all of our cheese former juvie
friends and that was all sparked because
Hiram finally opened his weird private
prism that we all totally forgot about
and oh my god this show is everything
okay anyways
Jughead and Archie and Friends raided
the gargoyle building like a video game
and then Jughead somehow survived a
pretty massive fall from a window and
then the episode ended with a chalice
filled with teeth and then FP stumbled
on baby teeth dead body or what's left
of them Jughead is now in a full-on war
against his evil mother Gladys but as
things are up to Cole Sprouse well
here's what he would actually like to
see from Jughead moving forward I think
it's about time Joe head walks a moral
gray area where he's had a propensity
for violence and irrationality and
emotional turmoil and he also has this
super rational side where he's an
investigator and he's a thinker and he's
taking a moral high ground I would like
to see him understand that he should be
doing bad in order to be doing good in
the long run which is something FP is
done in the past and something that
Gladys does willingly and maybe too
often we're a rather broody Bunch
he sort of accepts that if he's actually
going to lead a gang of young outcasts
he's got to be brutal I think it's one
of those interesting things as a
character because often times when
characters like Joe do bad the fans
react poorly and they say something like
oh well maybe he's not a good guy I
never really saw Jughead is kind of a
good guy I saw him as a very conflicted
human character that happens to be in
these extremely wild circumstance and it
would be interesting for me to see him
kind of lean into the fact that he
doesn't need to be the best guy he just
needs to be super cerebral about the
choices that he needs to make I like
Jughead as a kind of chess player when
he thinks about the things he's doing
and I think he ends up on top and that's
that's what I like when I see the
episodes I'll make this right do you
think Jughead should dip his toe into
the dark side shout out your thoughts in
the comments below as we switch into the
romantic side of things with seven
seconds in heaven
with Tony Reggie and Josie completely
m.i.a from this episode rude things with
veggie are chose II and Shani word
non-existent Cheryl did give me a mini
heart attack though when she cried her
crocodile tears to Evelyn to gain her
trust but thankfully things with Shoni
remain a okay
I think meanwhile we were treated to a
sweet barchi friendship scene and even
though nothing happened I personally
think that that brief platonic
interaction had more chemistry than
Olive veggie in our chose e scenes
together sorry not sorry no comment and
despite the fact that veronica was
actually the one who sent her mom dead
fish in order to try and convince her
father to protect Hermione and then make
him somehow realize that they shouldn't
split up yeah well Hyrum figured out his
daughters a fishy plan and had the lodge
marriage officially annulled this ship
has sailed me home but the scene that
I'm most excited to highlight right now
is the bug head bed moment now fresh off
of a mmm rendezvous the crime solving
duo was discussing their own upcoming
illegal activity and it was so cute and
so very bug head talk ever and although
I thought this scene was exactly what we
needed to partially quench the great bug
head drought of season 3 it also left me
with a lot of questions which of course
leads us into this week's rendition of
hisses and kisses right off the bat I
need to say that I'm not giving hisses
to this bug head pillow talk moment
I'm sending hisses to the confusion it
created in my brain after I rewatched it
a few times because obviously that's
what I did first of all where are they
is that Betty's old room is Jughead now
sleeping in Betty's room why are the
sheets pink maybe Betty didn't take her
furniture with her but surely she'd take
her sheets right or does Jughead
secretly like sleeping on pink sheets is
this their way of avoiding showing us
the whole room do they really think we
wouldn't notice all this economy Jaime
hisses - the fact that they reintroduced
us to baby teeth a character that I
could never take seriously because his
name is baby teeth only to then rip his
teeth out and kill him that was way
harsh bro I never even
other than these murders again by happy
minute this is that Kevin is now so
completely brainwashed that he's now the
official tour guide of the farm
Kevin babe you know that I would follow
you anywhere but I refuse to follow you
into that hellhole know if everyone will
follow me and I'll show you the garden
also hisses that it seems like we're
never actually going to see the farms
original farm headquarters animals
I need animals I want cows and pigs and
sheep like the one on Alice's broach and
hopefully there are some baby ducklings
or chicks wandering around those creepy
halls right let's go over the concept
one more time hisses - Edgar for being
so damned attractive that I can't
actually remember why I'm mad at him -
GLaDOS for seemingly hating her son so
much you're in the wrong here lady and
Hiram for proving that he would be a
really really bad actor and that of my
wife Hermione the love of my life
switching over to kisses Wow my biggest
kiss is going to our episode MVP for
this week miss Cheryl blossom excuse you
we are having a private conversation
can you leave I loved seeing all this
Betty Cheryl cousin bonding especially
that milkshake filled conversation also
kisses to Cheryl for not freaking out
over the fact that Betty was wearing a
red sweater also at least we got to know
the exact shade of red that Cheryl lumps
what's your favorite color red um V but
if I had to specify it's a pan tones
flame scarlet Oh and kisses to be in
these adorable besties telepathy of
course I'll go with you kisses - the
fact that things are finally getting
interesting again with this new the farm
lets me see dead people revelation -
Alice looking the lawless in that white
suit and Evelyn's hilariously bizarre
behavior during the farm interviews okay
so Evelyn I used to bite my nails but
now I've since stopped but I still bite
them when I'm stressed so what does that
mean do you want me to join the farm
I'll call you and we're done thank you
so much for joining me for this week's
Sweetwater after-show and I'll see you
next time for our Sweetwater preview of
episodes 318 as we gear up for the last
five episodes of season three in the
time please give this video a like and
then hit subscribe and pour all your
hearts out into the comments with your
hisses and kisses for the episode what
did you think about Edgar ever and ever
and the farms shocking secret did you
have the same bug head bed thoughts as
me and do you agree with Cole Sprouse
about jugheads journey shout it all out
and I'm sending kisses to you river
babes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]